the maker of the ride that broke apart
and killed one person at the Ohio State
Fair has ordered other festivals to stop
using it an entire section of the
fireball ride crashed to the ground on
Wednesday similar Ides at fairs across
the country are now closed seven people
were hurt 18-year old Tyler Gerald died
now he had just enlisted in the Marines
last week Adriana Diaz is at the Ohio
State Fairgrounds in Columbus Adriana
good morning good morning investigators
and inspectors are working around the
clock they were here last night and
they're in there right now reinfecting
the 73 other rides here this morning all
rides will still be closed but the park
will be open again thousands return to
the Ohio State Fairgrounds in Columbus
on Thursday less than 24 hours earlier
passengers were thrown into the air when
a carnival ride malfunctioned
we're gonna watch and participate and
document all the facts basically an
autopsy on that machine to make sure
that we get to the bottom of why it came
apart
despite the parks reopening all rides at
the fair have been shut down until they
can be reinfected what you want to make
sure of is that you check you recheck
you do the best you can but the ability
for human beings to avoid accidents and
you got to talk to the big guy upstairs
to figure that one out
the fireball also known as the
afterburner swings up to twenty four
riders 40 feet into the air while
spinning 13 times a minute in 2007 the
rides manufacturer issued a bulletin
advising all afterburner owners to test
for cracks after they were discovered in
one ride swingarm reviews done this week
showed the Columbus ride past a
comprehensive safety inspection
including checks for cracks a state
permit was issued on Wednesday the fairs
opening day his life just kind of made
you wanna laugh on Thursday family and
friends held a vigil for Tyler Darryl
the 18 year old enlisted in the Marines
less than a week ago he had a giving
heart Navy captain Gerrard Tom Lennon
jr. runs the Navy Junior ROTC program at
Franklin Heights High School where
Jarrell served as a cadet
here we have a young man who had found a
path and just a few days later gets cut
short my heart is just aching for that
family
the rides manufacturer kmg a Dutch
company said that that 2007 notice it
issued related to a welding problem on
another ride as for the operator of this
ride amusements of America they say they
are committed to determining the cause
of the incident Gayle I hope sure hope
so thank you very much Adriana